look at that halloween music wow look  outside right now guys  great shot of the moon hey we asked our  fellow anchors here  what your favorite candy was denise her  top one was baby ruth  brian reese's right it's an amazing  marriage between peanut butter and  chocolate  it really is you can't go wrong with it  kirsten  ferrero rochet roche very  very fancy very bougie wow that's what  i'm saying  like toblerone i guess butterfinger for  chris  yep of course and then me am i the only  one that knows what chicken stick is i  have no idea what chicken stick if you  guys know what chicken stick is  is that a candy yeah it's so good is it  a chicken candy  sounds like a beef jerky i'm gonna i'm  bringing some man for everybody can you  explain it ted not really  is this good everybody knows what baby  roots  70 centennial hills christmas summerlin  sound off on social media am i the only  one that knows what chico stick is i  love it